[Music]
and now
our favorite and esteemed director of
the American Freedom Defense
Initiative Pamela Geller will explain
further
thank you so much for coming God bless
you for coming um I'm going to keep my
remarks Abridged because I want you to
hear the people that are on the de um
couple of uh brief we're gonna I'm going
to go into the trailer for 10 minutes
but first I want to warn you that it
it's very it's very graphic I told the
911 family members I suggested they
leave
and uh I wasn't doing it to be
provocative it was a very difficult film
to make it's difficult to watch but
these are images you have not
seen uh 911 has been uh
whitewashed when I uh went to put an ad
uh on the New York city buses I was
prohibited by the New York City Transit
Authority because I had a picture of
that day with the planes going into the
tower
and I was told that those images were
embargoed and so they might be offensive
so
okay a historical image an accurate
historical image is embargoed because it
might be
offensive but a 15-story mega mosque in
a building that was destroyed at Ground
Zero is is
not so I think part of the problem is it
9911 has been whitewashed and if any of
you were well you're certainly old
enough to have experienced that day live
you know what you were thinking you were
thinking we are at
War which is a natural and healthy
response and you have been conditioned
in these past nine years by an Islamic
supremacist narrative that's what it is
the enforcement of sharia do not defame
Islam do not insult Islam in Muslim
countries if you defame or insult Islam
it's blasphemy and they kill you they
kill you look what's happening in
Pakistan look what's happening in
Indonesia look what's happening uh
across the world in the
west if you defame or insult Islam it's
character
assassination many people have come to
me said you know I don't know maybe I
don't want your name affiliated with it
you know and I understand it's perfectly
fine and I said Just remember when you
take these actions you are Pamela Geller
it ain't Pamela Geller it's what Pamela
Geller is saying you are a racist
islamophobic anti-muslim bigot that's
what happens and why why is that it's to
shut you up do not shut
up the worst thing that I have
seen is I'm used to the attacks but when
you have 911 family members
who suffered the greatest loss who took
the hit for us because every one of us
is a 9911 family member they just were
in they just were there and when you see
them being
victimized
again for voicing their
opinions that is the second wave of the
911 attacks so I'm going to ask Rich to
start the film it's going to be 10
minutes I suggest you leave if uh if you
have a um
uh low threshold for such things but I
believe it needed to be part of the
movie uh because you have to see it in
its context thank you very much for
coming and not seeing Ron
[Applause]
Paul there is a black smoke coming from
both of the towers uh it's a horrific
scene
here
that was the sound of someone
falling someone
dying it was Raining
Bodies make no mistake a September 11th
it was an act of War you want to hear
that there were people that were so
frighten
that they jumped out of buildings and
they exploded on impact you want to hear
that the were dismembered bodies there's
things that we haven't spoken
about innocent victims in the wrong
place at the wrong time the World Trade
Center in New York
City it was chosen as a symbolic Target
not by the murderers themselves but by
men who sent them on a mission men with
religious titles like shik Bin Laden
Imam
Al first I'd like very much for you to
uh give a a warm welcome to Rosaline
Town who is very
[Applause]
thanful